[Musique]
il ya plein de voix de supporters qui
s'élèvent pour sa rebaptisé le stage
orange vélodrome le stade bernard tapie
on rappelle que bernard tapie a été bien
sûr président de l'olympique de
marseille entre 1986 et 1995 et c'est
lui qui a permis à l'olympique de
marseille de remporter la seule ligue
des champions remportée par un club
français c'était attend 93 hier soir
lors de leur match à lille les joueurs
de l'om portaient un brassard noir le
stade a rendu un hommage à l'ancien
homme d'affaires avec une photo diffusée
sur les écrans et les applaudissements
nourris des supporters c'est un escroc
il a sali le football comme jamais avec
le scandale de valenciennes il est
discrédité c'est comme si on donnait le
nom de dominique strauss-kahn à un
couvent où débarquent à usak non mais
n'exagérons pas c'est un escroc qui a
été condamné qu'à fait de la prison il
elle il est l'incarnation de cette
dérive sociétale immoral de la gauche
qui serait congédié avec le fric et le
business tapie faisait le chanteur a 25
ans et le chef d'entreprise à 30 il a
dansé avec véronique et davina il a
tourné avec lelouch interpréter le
commissaire valence pour tf1 chanter
avec barbelivien il a acheté adidas
éparpillés rocard séduit mitterrand
combattu le pen il a connu l'assemblée
nationale et la prison de la santé
bernard tapie n'était pas fait du même
bois que les autres hommes on ne donne
pas le nom d'un voyou à un stade de
football surtout à marseille j'adore si
on veut donner un nom la prison des
baumettes et jean-bernard
supportait pas la critique peu la
contradiction que la contradiction est
par exemple on peut faire oublier il n'a
jamais voulu venir dans les grandes
gueules parce que dans les grandes
gueules parfois on avait discuté de
tapis de ses affaires et c'est avec
laquelle on peut dire sa petite phrase
oui on peut le dire parce que vous avez
nommé ayedi j'aime bien les grandes
gueules mais j'aime pas les gros cons
vous répondez simplement tomber les
grands comptes et les ventes aux 6m en
moi je suis un peu ennuyé avec eric z
avec eric blanc avec laurent ruquier je
veux dire le tapis d'abord j'aime bien
et je travaille avec lui et rtl ont
mélangé patapon risée mis mes enfants
que ce qu'on ait le temps de
faire un dernier adieu à bernard
mauresmo était zemmour mieux tout ça non
écoutez moi mais je vis pendant que vous
parlez vais pas la voix s'élève la voix
si pendant que vous parlez moi je me
tais je ne reste pas calme je ne reste
pas calme si je connais ce truc pour
être président il faut être calme je
m'en fous bon ben ok faisons pression
aux gens mais oui je ferais thon rouge
et les occurrences j'aimerais bien pour
vous connaissiez d'un discours qui est
bon frais look et je vous écoute vous
écoute vous m'écoutez pas jeu finalement
zemmour le pen pas moi franchement si
l'un d'eux passe je vais regretter
d'arrêter pourquoi parce que les comics
vont se faire des couilles en or
humoriste des comptes avec la peine et
vous vous avez pas arrêté déjà il n'est
pas président vous arrêtez pas imaginer
ça va occuper vous vivo ça va être
génial et puis à tous les anciens
ministres de nicolas sarkozy alors eux
ils sont en train j'ai bien compris de
chercher le moyen de chercher le moyen
de chercher le moyen de se départager
pour savoir lequel ou laquelle se
présentera devant les français je leur
souhaite bon courage je suis convaincu
d'une chose il en va de la politique
comme de l'amour on ne réchauffe pas les
plats si tu vois j'aime beaucoup mon
pantalon à ce moment là oui c'est
s'asseyant ça tranche
ça transperce pas une dalle gérard
manset tu vu dans les points
trop fraîche
et mulets book c'est na kim a coiffé moi
je m'en fous je fais pas ma taille ouais
mais bon tu te sens tu es belle
genre moi je suis un congélateur à moi
tout seul bonjour fraîche nouvelle
barbie est les cosmonautes cette fois ci
elle a pris les traits la poupée de
l'astronaute italienne samantha
cristoforetti qui doit rejoindre la
station spatiale internationale au
printemps prochain alors la poupée
barbie a même effectué un vol
parabolique sous l'oeil des photographes
de l'agencé européenne de l'espace voyez
un bref voilà en apesanteur de quelques
une vingtaine de secondes avec de vrais
astronautes aux formations
sinon ils ne sont pas gigogne ici dans
le sens ou dans l'autre sens à bon
[Musique]
[Rires]
je vous aide pas beaucoup certes mais
voilà elles sont les gones voici qu'elle
allait pète je vais donc chez dont vous
êtes aussi blonde commence
très content à ce
que vous dites la chambre savez comment
c'est chandon se chante la ligue pour
réussir dans ce métier passer par la
chambre c'est pas mal non plus
ce ne sera pas la forme énorme et vidé
[Applaudissements]
saison
c'est bien coûteuse c'est
assez facile à manger tue la trappe à
pleines mains tu le manges
crois que
j'ai décidé de tout mettre dans son
assiette merci cher nicolas est
quasiment le même le même et c'est
yolande c'est vrai que vous abordez vous
mordez françois duval
oui bon c'est vrai on à droite bandée du
palais exactement à gauche le grand
hamster se montre de plus en plus
frénétique
à droite sa collègue reste de marbre
le maïs semble provoqua chez le rongeur
une crise de démence
[Musique]
il m'arrive est un langage de charretier
oui mais mokssit tu m'as pas vu conduire
en fait
je traite les autres de communistes
une alimentation basée uniquement sur du
maïs provoque une carence en vitamine b3
à l'évidence cette carence le rend fou
et renforce son instinct agressif
[Musique]
avec à la clé cette macabre découverte
100% des femelles nous rien s'ils ont
tué leur propre petit mais vous avez
créé une serbe de l'avant
franchement
trop
trop trop
[Musique]
taper un commis hier soir donc
reconnu
c'est un rappel
sur vous c'était vraiment me handfield a
été bonne et elle s'en est pas me jeter
nue on doit donc commencer par le maire
un doigt dans le vert